the Joe Rogan experience sometimes you
have to do that to people
what hey man I didn't get your call
[Music]
is it better off to say hey I find you a
little annoying and very needy and so
when I get a phone call from you often I
cringe I do like you and I do our time
but sometimes I just can't sometimes I
can't that's probably the most healthy
version but you can't say that no you
can't you have to go like this he'll go
I didn't you did today oh [ __ ] I didn't
see ya sorry Manny I didn't see it did
you not get my text that's when people
that bothered did you not get my text I
always say sorry I didn't respond to
your text I try to say that first but
let me tell you something as a man if I
text you and I'll get a text back I
don't get it with that I don't get a
[ __ ] butt hurt right no I just go
that's let's it
he saw it it is what it is we move I
don't send a text in needing or if I
needed a real response from you I would
call you and go hey I need to talk to
you about something you ever have
someone send you a text it's like a
little on the needy side and then they
send you one like three minutes later it
says hello every day question every
[ __ ] day Jaime every day to me when
are you coming over when are you coming
over I'm common Jay leave me alone from
our afternoon pump session you know some
people just get real weird with like
them sending them messages in a bottle
and then there's a little message did
you get it and then the other side of it
is Bobby Lee who literally never
answered a text ever ever ever ever I've
sent him a thousand texts for him yeah
he doesn't answer
good for you his green you know his
notification is like 800 [ __ ] little
red you know he never answers he doesn't
give a [ __ ] but I kind of but everyone
who's friends with him knows that's just
Bobby yeah Joey just calls you yeah Joey
a lot more I've been calling people a
lot moments more personal what's also
like you can't call as many people as
you can text and I think there's an
overload of communication that occurs
when you're texting with like 10
different friends at the same time I got
dude sending me videos of them kicking
pads and people shun me back I mean look
at this fish I caught like I [ __ ] get
these texts all day from all these crazy
interesting people imagine if I got that
many phone calls in a day it would be in
st. turn your food be like hey what's up
man hold on hold on someone's calling me
hey what's up Tom you never write you
know I'm saying like you would never if
you think about even if you have like
three friends and you're texting to the
back and forth throughout today make
jokes maybe you know like a group chat
like right a lot of us from group chats
yes toggle a shed and show
ridiculous pictures she would get me
kicked out of the country
oh yeah sure right god I mean that you
would never do that if it was phone
calls you'd be like you needy [ __ ] I
gotta call you all day yeah I'm calling
you in the morning that I'm calling in
the afternoon are we [ __ ] like what's
happening even if we work if you needed
me to call you that many times in a day
Blake hey hey hey like we got a we got
to be happy to being alone too yeah we
happy be together but also you got to be
able to be alone yeah if you need phone
calls all day long hey hey hey hey hey
chill out chill blank out a text is good
because you could be in the middle of
some [ __ ] right if you're one of them
dudes is inclined to change the
transmission you want to rebuild an old
Chrysler or something like that you
could be under there that a little text
message I'll get back to figure that out
that's my cat Shane maybe real quick
yeah we're gonna meet at 8:00 you know
like it's minimal yeah right there's
nothing to it
[Applause]